[Musik]
hat einige, die ausgesprochen rassistisch sind, und
einige, die einfach glauben, was ihnen
gesagt wurde
Jahre, die sie hätten
tun sollen oder schon vor langer Zeit getan haben, also
mag ich die Tatsache, dass er die einzige Person ist
, die sich dazu geäußert hat, die sehr proaktiv zu sein scheint,
um das zu erledigen
[Musik]
Jobs Bildung Lebensqualität eine bessere
Qualität  Leben und wir müssen nur
lernen, einander zu lieben und zu respektieren
[Musik]
das ist es diesmal, ja, Sir, wie der
Präsidentschaftskampf der stärkste in
diesem Rennen ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wirst du tun, was du gesagt hast, tust du,
tust du nicht  brauche jemanden, der
heute eines verspricht, wenn er
gewählt wird und du weißt, dass er verschwindet
[Musik]